zdf heute live herzlich willkommen ja
unser thema heute sperrstunde gegen
korona es hatte sich angebahnt die
großstädte werden zunehmend zu hotspots
schon in den vergangenen tagen war in
berlin oft die rede davon mittlerweile
ist es eine großstadt nach der anderen
die elf bürgermeister der elf deutschen
größten städte waren heute bei der
kanzlerin ein ganzes maßnahmenpaket
haben sie dort beschlossen es geht vor
allem um verschärfungen masken pflicht
sperrstunde keine großen feiern beginnen
daher noch detaillierter darauf ein
wir sind an vielen meinungen heute
interessiert wie immer an diesem ort
bezirksbürgermeister neukölln wird unser
gesprächspartner sein
auch angela merkel und ihr dringender
appell an die jugendlichen wird zu hören
sein
vor allem aber sind wir an eurer meinung
interessiert hier in den kommentaren und
natürlich auch wie immer unter zdf heute
- live at zdf.de vor allem wollen wir
aber nicht über die jugendlichen reden
sondern mit den jugendlichen deshalb
schalten wir jetzt live nach frankfurt
zum hotspot dort ist nina niebergall auf
der bergerstraße schönen guten abend die
am freitagabend 20.30 was genau wir
stehen jetzt hier mitten in frankfurt an
der bergerstraße das ist normalerweise
nicht irgendwo freitags abends viel los
ist man merkt schon es sind nicht so
viele leute hier
man muss dazu allerdings auch sagen es
regnet hier das heißt vielleicht liegt
es auch ein bisschen daran aber man
merkt das sind neue maßnahmen in kraft
auch die berger straße die es hier
direkt hinter uns da gilt masken pflicht
bis 22 uhr
auch weil es eben tagsüber eine
einkaufsstraße ist
was stunden gesammelt und mit den leuten
dort vor ort gesprochen was ist so die
meinung was sagen sie ja ich hab sogar
zwei kneipengänger hier bei mir stehen
das sind der chor unter mag die waren
hier eben in der kneipe und sind jetzt
für uns mal raus gekommen und denen
würde ich jetzt einfach meine frage
stellen und zwar vielleicht erst mal an
dich
wie findest du denn die neuen maßnahmen
also vor allem auch die sperrstunde und
auch das alkoholverbot auf öffentlichen
plätzen
na ja also es kommt natürlich auf dem
platz an sicherlich ist es für den
bahnhof ein bisschen schwieriger
umzusetzen
generell ist es natürlich für die wirte
ist kann ich sehr gut verstehen
gerade auch bei dem sommer der hinter
uns liegt nicht so prickelnd dass er
jetzt zwei stunden weniger einnahmen auf
sie zukommen von daher ist er kritisch
und wie ist es denn für euch also ihr
müsst ihr jetzt ist es freitagabend eine
arbeitswoche liegt im zeit hinter einem
ihr müsst ihr zum 23 uhr nach hause wie
findet ihr das
also ich versteh grundsätzlich die zeit
eingrenzung der zeiten mich deswegen ich
meine ab ob man ab 23 uhr in der bar
noch drin sitzt oder davor schon drin
gesessen ist das macht für mich
eigentlich relativ wenig unterschied
andererseits verstehe ich auch die
grundlage dahinter nicht diese
zeitbegrenzung zu machen also wenn man
mir genauer erklären würde warum jetzt
diese 23 uhr begrenzung da wäre dann
würde ich vielleicht auch akzeptieren
und besser verstehen können
letzte frage die politiker die sprechen
ja jetzt in letzter zeit häufig gerade
die jungen leute appellieren auch dass
man sich etwas zurückhalten soll nicht
so viele freunde treffen auch nicht so
viel trinken soll damit eben die
hemmschwelle nicht so sehr feld könnt
ihr das nachvollziehen dass da das das
da die appelle immerhin die jungen gehen
möchte ja durchaus also ich finde also
ich hab es bei mir selbst gemerkt setzt
wie bei dem sommer hat sich so langsam
gewöhnt man denkt okay man hat so ein
bisschen die konsequenzen jetzt auch im
blick und denke nicht mehr so kritisch
darüber nach wie das vielleicht im
frühling war ich kann mich noch erinnern
im frühling da war man sie kritischer
wenn man vielleicht einfach nur so zum
spiel war mit vier personen eingeladen
hat jetzt sprechen alle auf einmal von
house partys weil es natürlich auch
draußen kälter ist nichtsdestotrotz ist
das risiko genau so groß wie vorher
auf der anderen seite muss man natürlich
einfach mit menschenverstand dran gehen
und wenn man das maß halten kann es ist
in ordnung ich würde dann ich sagen
generell alkoholverbot sondern
vielleicht irgendwo einschränken er ist
natürlich auch schwierig das zu
kontrollieren
ja
ganz herzlichen dank an euch beide ja
und greift wir haben auch noch hier
andere stimmen uns natürlich angehört
von leuten die hier heute abend auf der
berger straße unterwegs waren und die
hören wir uns jetzt mal an ich finde
nicht gerechtfertigt ist übertrieben
also ich finde eine gewisse maßnahmen
sollten seien natürlich auch die ältere
menschen schützen wie ein altersheim und
so aber nicht jetzt das jetzt also ich
komme sowieso die bevölkerung immer mehr
weiter runter drücken und wir haben halt
gar nichts mehr zu sagen und keine
meinungsäußerung mehr und wer hat
dagegen geht muss ja wie gesagt strafen
zahlen und es ist einfach nicht
gerechtfertigt also schwer stunde ist
wenn das macht schon sind gerade mit
alkohol das wird dann auch zu späteren
zeiten tendenziell eher ein bisschen
schlimmer also das kann ich schon
nachvollziehen
also ist nimmt an der lebensqualität und
im alltag unglaublich viel weg also zu
frankfurt gehört das dazu sich auf
plätzen zu treffen also nach markt auf
dem friedberger markt in bornheim und
wenn das ganze leben nicht mehr so
stattfinden kann wie sollen stattfinden
ist das geht viel verloren und das ist
irgendwie echt bedrückend
ja wir haben es gehört es gibt
unterschiedliche meinungen zu dem thema
und gerade auch die letzte passantin hat
es ja gesagt das alkoholverbot auf
öffentlichen plätzen was hier in
frankfurt auch gilt das sieht man hier
auch die plätze sind tatsächlich leer
und das stadtbild ist an diesem
freitagabend hier in frankfurt
tatsächlich ein ganz anderes andere
stimme an der stelle an dem wir kommen
wir gleich zurück zu dir nina aber
vielleicht mal gerade den leiter des
gesundheitsamtes von frankfurt rené
gottschalk
wir arbeiten seit dem ersten februar
dieses jahres sieben tage die woche und
wir stellen jetzt eben fest dass
insbesondere durch die privaten feiern
und durch unsachgemäße besucher in den
gaststätten und und clubs dass es
dadurch jetzt eine ausbreitung in der
fläche gegeben hat glücklicherweise eben
junge leute die aber dann natürlich
potenziell älterer die gefährdet sind an
diesem virus schwer zu erkranken
anstecken können und das muss verhindert
werden
nina kommt dieses argument an herrscht
so etwas wie einsicht auch was diesen
punkt betrifft der wird ja immer wieder
gern genannt
ja das würde ich schon sagen also ich
haben viele leute gesagt dass sie
natürlich darauf bedacht sind keine
anderen leute anzustecken gerade auch
ältere das ist aber eben auch
verhältnismäßigkeit ankommt auch dieser
punkt wurde ja von vielen genannt
also von daher ja es herrscht einsicht
und man muss aber natürlich auch sagen
wir sind jetzt hier im frankfurter
norden hier ist heute nicht besonders
viel los man weiß aber natürlich nicht
was in den privaten wohnzimmern passiert
ob die leute vielleicht auch nach
drinnen ausweichen und da kann man es
natürlich auch nicht kontrollieren
vielen dank für den moment gekommen
gleich zu dir zurück dazu passen die
ersten kommentare die hier reinkommen ja
da heißt es eben auch die jugendlichen
kaufen sich dann tagsüber den alkohol
und feiern dann abends trotzdem lola
montez wie ihr facebook- oder eben auch
die stimme masken unter freiem himmel
sagt katharina heckmann auf facebook das
sei einfach nur lächerlich fragen wir
nach in berlin beim bezirksbürgermeister
des bezirks neukölln martin hikel einen
monat nach berlin erstmal schon guten
abend ja wir haben gerade so einige
argumente schon gehört können sie die
grundsätzlich verstehen
ich kann die absolut verstehen weil das
ist schon eine echte umstellung wenn man
letztendlich jetzt in seinem
alltäglichen verhalten so eingeschränkt
wird wenn er solche maßnahmen ergriffen
werden dass man nach 23 uhr eigentlich
nicht nur in den kneipen unterwegs sein
kann dass man seinen seiner privaten
feiern einschränken musste es sind schon
einschnitte und da kann ich durchaus
nachvollziehen dass man da sicherlich
auch fragen stellt aber ich glaube
trotzdem dass diese maßnahmen wirklich
wichtig sind
es ist ja oft schon verboten aber auch
von geboten die rede warum setzen so oft
und so viele auf eben besagte verbote na
ja letztendlich sind ja diese verbote
geben ja faktisch eigentlichen rahmen
her also dass man auf der einen seite
feststellen muss dass ich über den
sommer wurde das infektionsgeschehen
wirklich im verhältnis sehr harmlos war
die neue infektionszahlen sehr gering
gewesen sind
und dass man das aber den bürgerinnen
und bürgern sicher durch aus dem alltag
im verhalten wieder eingeschlichen hat
was nicht mal böse gemeint ist was
einfach so passiert dass man sich wieder
mit mehreren freunden trifft
dass man wieder viele besucher macht
dass man sich auch vielleicht wieder
umarmt dass man sich zur begrüßung die
hand gibt und das ist durchaus dinge die
haben sich mit mit sicherheit im laufe
des sommers wieder eingeschlichen und
das allerdings ist jetzt eine situation
die in der kalten jahreszeit und auf die
füße fallen kann
und da ist schon richtig zu sagen man
gibt einen rahmen vor ob man gibt auch
das signal dass wir eben eine pandemie
ja haben und das finde ich ein normales
jahr haben wo heute noch der geburtstag
wie immer gefeiert werden kann sondern
wo man halt leider auf die große feier
verzichten muss gerade jetzt im herbst
und im winter
sie sind ja nicht nur amtsträger sondern
wie wir alle auch privatpersonen
unterscheidet sich ihre persönliche
meinung von ihrer beruflichen nicht
wirklich also ich habe großes
verständnis dafür und ich habe
verständnis dafür dass sich junge
menschen um ihren sommer betrogen führen
dass sich junge menschen vielleicht wenn
sie abitur gemacht haben nicht die
großen feiern machen konnten dass wir
nicht fahren konnten
das geburtstage ausgefallen sind dass
viele veranstaltungen ausgefallen sind
das sind alle schon dinge die man das
gefühl bekommen kann der sommer und das
jahr ist mir irgendwie verloren gegangen
im sage ich mal in der aspekt der
fröhlichen gelegenheiten und das stimmt
ja auch
aber auf der anderen seite haben wir
halt auch eine pandemie und auf der
anderen seite haben wir auch noch alle
gut die bilder aus italien am kopf die
furchtbar gewesen sind und genau das war
ja auch der grund warum man im
märz/april diese wirklich sehr harten
maßnahmen ergriffen hatte um ihm genau
sowas zu verhindern
wir haben solche bilder nicht bekommen
das ist gut so wir müssen aber auch
dafür sorgen dass sie diese bilder in
zukunft nicht bekommen und insofern hat
sie schon für richtig da auch im rahmen
zu setzen indem man sich jetzt egal in
diesem besonderen jahr wie man sich
verhalten soll und was man besonders
viel achtsamkeit auch geben soll um auch
seinen nächsten um das
infektionsgeschehen nicht weiter haben
sich ausbreiten zu lassen
anders als im märz bei der ersten welle
als wir vor allem viele ältere menschen
von kogit 19 betroffen waren und
entsprechend die sterblichkeit ziemlich
hoch lag ist es diesmal anders schauen
wir uns mal hier die grafe
kann ich habe ja auf dem laptop die
offizielle seite von berlin und wenn man
sich das hier anschaut kann man hier
rechts sehen wirklich wie so ein baum
der hoch geht klar bei den ganz jungen 0
bis 4 sind es noch recht wenige dann
steigt es doch sehr deutlich an und hier
kann man sehen der höhepunkt ist
erreicht bei den 20 bis 24 jährigen das
wie gesagt ist das bild aus berlin 25
bis 29 geht es schon merklich zurück und
dann sieht man hier bei den älteren
entsprechend deutlich geringer
das heißt diese welle ist eine andere
als die erste was heißt das für sie und
was heißt dass tatsächlich für ihre
maßnahmen also ich weiß nicht ob diese
welle anderes als die lieber vielleicht
schon gehabt haben weil ich glaube dass
wir märz/april einfach auch viel weniger
tests gehabt haben wir hatten allerdings
wesentlich mehr ergebnisse in den
krankenhäusern wir hatten tatsächlich
auch wesentlich mehr todesfälle die mit
dem virus im zusammenhang stehen und
standen und dementsprechend lässt sich
das glaube ich gar nicht miteinander
vergleichen weil man einfach im
märz/april viel weniger erkenntnisse hat
wir haben jetzt ein wesentlich eine
wesentlich höhere quote antesten
dementsprechend sieht man einfach mehr
und dementsprechend kann man auch früher
intervenieren bevor dieses
infektionsgeschehen jetzt von den jungen
leuten die robuste teams vielleicht gar
nicht so sehr stört die damit leben und
die auch vielleicht sogar sagen naja was
solls also mich interessiert nicht
großartig
ich bin körperlich fit ich bin gesund
aber die wahrscheinlichkeit steigt
natürlich mit einer höheren verbreitung
dass es irgendwann auch in dem
bevölkerungsgruppen landet die ihm
gesundheitlich nicht mehr so fit sind
die vielleicht vorerkrankungen haben die
zur älteren generation gehören und das
gilt es zu verhindern und insofern lässt
es sich tatsächlich nicht wirklich
vergleichen wir haben aber ein ziemlich
gutes frühwarnsystem untersagt uns
momentan dass die zahlen sehr steil nach
oben gehen und dass wir hier tatsächlich
auch die bremse ziehen müssen damit wir
im schlimmeres verhindern können
auf neukölln haben viele geschaut in den
vergangenen tagen
was ist ihr größtes problem bei coop 19
derzeit das hat der eine kollege auch
gerade schon in seinem beitrag gesagt da
gesund der leiter des gesundheitsamtes
aus frankfurt dass wir ein ziemlich
diffus infektionsgeschehen haben das ist
nicht der eine hotspot ist es nicht die
eine veranstaltung es sind viele
private feiern sind kleine besucher ist
es passiert im bekanntenkreis und das
nicht nur eins zwei drei oder viermal
sondern es passiert dutzende male
und das wiederum ist damit verbunden das
dann natürlich die nachverfolgung sehr
aufwendig ist weil jeder einzelne
infizierte hatte ja unter umständen im
schnitt zwischen 20 und 40 kontakten
dieses gilt nach zu verfolgen und ich
möchte mal als einfache beispiele
bemühen wenn sie 40 infizierte haben
deren kontakte sie nachverfolgen müssen
dann haben sie letztendlich kontakte in
einer summe von zwischen 800 und 1600
menschen die sie dann abtelefonieren
müssen und in erfahrung bringen müssen
und das ist schon eine ganz ganz
ordentliche wucht und dementsprechend es
ist schon so dass wir sagen können
das infektionsgeschehen das sehr breit
es ist sehr wenn die breite gestreut es
gibt nicht den einen infektionsherd und
das wiederum deutet ganz klar darauf hin
dass das virus sich in der breite auch
wieder verteilt und das darum auch die
schwierigkeit und die möglichkeit
besteht dass letztendlich dann
irgendwann auch dieses virus im
bevölkerungsreichen ankommt die
wesentlich stärker sind und dass es
durchaus bin sehr gefährliche sache und
wir können also feststellen es ist in
der breite misst sich die reine
infektionsherd und das heißt das ist
quasi letztendlich sicher in allen
bevölkerungsschichten über kurz oder
lang unter umständen zeigen wird martini
gesprächen gleich weiter wollen einmal
schnell auf die bundeskanzlerin zu
sprechen kommen die hatte heute ein
treffen im kanzleramt mit den
bürgermeistern ich sagte es und
hinterher ging sie vor die presse und
hat einen wirklich dringenden appell
gerade an die jugendlichen gerichtet
mein appell gerade auch an jüngere
menschen die es vielleicht übertrieben
finden wie jetzt in den städten in das
ausgehen und feiern eingegriffen wird
denken auch sie einmal an das was ihnen
am wichtigsten ist ist es sich die
gesundheit ihrer familie auch der
großeltern
ist es nicht auch in den nächsten jahren
gute ausbildungs und arbeitschancen zu
haben die nun einmal an einer starken
wirtschaft hängen ist es dafür nicht
wert jetzt ein wenig geduldig zu sein
einschränkungen beim feiern zu ertragen
die ja immer zeitweilig sind und an das
zielgebiet
sind die infektionszahlen unter eine
bestimmte schwelle zu drücken
alles wird zurückkommen feiern ausgehen
spaß ohne coroner regeln jetzt aber
erzählt etwas anderes achtsamkeit und
zusammenhalt das wird zurückkommen
feiern ausgehen spaß jetzt aber zählen
achtsamkeit und zusammenhalt nina in
frankfurt noch mal auf wie viel gehör
stößt dieser abhält also wir hören hier
sehr viel verständnis tatsächlich also
die leute wollen natürlich auch die
jungen leute wollen natürlich andere
nicht gefährden also alles was sozusagen
dem dienlich ist dass die andere nicht
gefährden das verstehen die leute hier
sehr gut wo wir einige kritische stimmen
gehört haben ist eben an den punkten
dass jetzt die sperrstunde um 23 uhr ist
da fragen sich einige wieso nicht um 0
uhr was bringt diese eine stunde oder
auch wir stehen hier an der bergerstraße
das ist auch eine einkaufsstraße hier
herrscht bis 22 uhr masken pflicht hier
ist allerdings nicht mehr besonders viel
los deshalb sagen auch einige leute
wieso müssen wir sogar im freien maske
tragen aber wie gesagt es gibt diese
einzelnen kritischen punkte überwiegend
herrscht verständnis und über
überwiegend herrscht guter wille wir
noch mal vielleicht ein paar stimmen
dazu kraft dabei via youtube schreibt
ich gehöre auch zu jugendlich möchte mit
denen die das tun aber nicht gerne in
einen topf geworfen werden oder anne m
auch via youtube wenn sie sich mal alle
ein bisschen anstrengen würden und
sichern alles halten dann hätten wir
nicht so lange damit zu tun aber es gibt
halt immer wieder diese idioten die
feiern müssen nach den hiekel noch mal
nach berlin sie haben es vorhin schon
mal gesagt die nachverfolgung danke aber
erstmal für den moment des gleichen die
nachverfolgung ist ein punkt sie haben
also auch wirklich viel damit zu tun sie
haben das rechenexempel aufgemacht jetzt
kamen heute unter anderem heraus dass
auch das rk ii also das robert koch
institut und die bundeswehr auch bei den
gesundheitsämtern helfen soll brauchen
sie das und wie macht sich das bisher
bemerkbar für sie das ist eine gute
unterstützung von der bundeswehr an vom
rk ii wir haben das glück dass wir schon
seit vielen monaten von der bundeswehr
im land bieten unterstützung bekommen
allein
haben wir 27 soldaten die bei uns tätig
sind die bei uns in der betreuung
unterstützen und jahren nachverfolgen
unterstützen können genauso wie auch
menschen vom rkw uns unterstützen und
ich glaube das ist auch wirklich
notwendig weil man darf nicht vergessen
die zahl die ich gerade genannt habe die
schon ziemlich hoch und da kann einfach
eine gesundheitsamt jede helfende hand
gebrauchen und insofern bin ich da sehr
dankbar dass dieses zeichen jetzt auch
noch mal offiziell kommuniziert worden
ist und dass dann auch andere kommunen
davon gebrauch machen können weil am
ende es ist eine gemeinschaftsaufgabe
die gesundheitsämter hiermit zu leisten
haben
und insofern ist es eine gute ein gutes
signal wie nah sind wir denn daran dass
die gesundheitsämter die kontrolle
verlieren
das lässt sich so pauschal gar nicht
sagen ich habe da mal sagen das ist
natürlich immer schwieriger wird für die
gesundheits einem tag
je mehr infizierte wir haben man kann
sicherlich durch rechtsverordnungen
durch allgemeinverfügung wege finden um
die nachverfolgung etwas effizienter zu
gestalten
aber wir dürfen uns nichts vormachen
dass wenn die zahlen irgendwann ins
vierstellige nehmen wir anders werden
worst case in köln 1 4 stelligen wunder
köln gehen würden dann wäre das durchaus
katastrophalen dann hätten wir ein
echtes problem
und insofern gilt es tatsächlich die
neuen fraktions zahlen so gering zu
halten dass die gesundheitsämter anlage
sind es nach zu verfolgen um halt
weitere einschränkungen auch zu
verhindern weil ich glaube was wir alle
wollen dass wir grüne was wir alle
brauchen und wollen ist dass schulen
offen bleiben dass die kitas offenland
dass die soziale infrastruktur offen
bleibt das auch gewerbe offen bleiben
kann
auch wenn es eingeschränkt ist sowie der
schulbetrieb auch eingeschränktes aber
wir müssen verhindern dass es dort zu
großflächigen schließung kommt weil ein
lock down in form von schließen von
schulen oder kitas wäre für familien für
die kinder wäre eine katastrophe das
haben wir jetzt auch aus den
schließungen die uns im frühen frühjahr
gehabt haben letztendlich auch gelehrt
und insofern du schon ganz klar die
schulen und die kitas müssen offen
bleiben und da vermutet
infektionsgeschehen beherrschbar bleiben
es gab viel kritik in letzter zeit an
der stadt berlin einige haben sich daher
vor getan hätte man diese maßnahmen die
jetzt ergriffen wurden vermeiden können
war berlin zu lax das würde ich nicht
sagen man kann von außen leicht sagen in
berlin
würde das alles ganz furchtbar oder
stimmen laufen kann ich auch an der
stelle so nicht stehen lassen
die infektionszahlen sondern jetzt in
den letzten monaten wirklich angestiegen
und das war auch absehbaren durch die
kalte jahreszeit und man darf auch nicht
vergessen wenn man über berlin spricht
entsprechend über 3,7 millionen menschen
die auf einen bruchteil der fläche eines
flächenlandes leben das heißt wesentlich
höher verdichtet wesentlich mehr
angebote an freizeit wesentlich mehr
gastronomien tausende von gewerben
tausende von cafés und kneipen und
restaurants und das ist natürlich sind
viele gelegenheiten wo menschen
zusammenkommen das heißt die mobilität
dass hier viel höher
die menschen begegnen sich viel häufiger
und dementsprechend ist es auch nur
letztendlich in so einem biologischen
prozess nachvollziehbar und logisch dass
in diesem hoch verdichteten städten so
eine infektionsgeschehen das wesentlich
leichter hat als in der fläche uns
insofern kann man das nicht pauschal
berlin sagen und das kann man
letztendlich auch an den anderen städten
sehen großstädten sehen die momentan
auch mit steigenden infektionszahlen zu
kämpfen haben es ist stichwort ich sage
das eingangs schon elf bürgermeister der
elf größten deutschen städte war heute
im kanzleramt mit einem kanzlerin merkel
schauen wir mal bevor wir gleich weiter
sprechen was da zusammengekommen ist
eine anzahl herausgekommen ist eine
zusammenfassung warten auf den corona
test im berliner stadtbezirk neukölln
sind die zahlen der mit 19 infizierten
besonders dramatisch gestiegen
viele versuchen mit deinem negativ test
dem corona hotspot in den herbstferien
noch irgendwie zu entfliehen
angesichts solcher wachsenden
infektionszahlen drängte die kanzlerin
im gespräch darauf zusätzliche maßnahmen
einzuführen
es muss unser ziel sein die
infektionszahlen in einem bereich zu
halten wo möglichst jeder einzelne
infektion nachverfolgt werden kann wo
kontaktpersonen erreicht und gewarnt
werden können und wo ist dann gelingt
infektionsketten auch wieder zu
durchbrechen ab 50 neuinfektionen pro
100.000 einwohner soll es umgehend neue
beschränkungen geben etwa masken pflicht
sperrstunden alkohol und kontaktverbot
mehr personal zum beispiel für
gesundheitsämter soll dann vom bund
kommen wir können abfordern
auch experten des robert koch institutes
unter bundeswehr für die krisenstäbe im
zweifel würde auch die bundespolizei auf
anfrage helfen bei den kontrollen auch
medizinstudenten und abordnungen aus
verwaltungen sollen mithelfen
gesundheits und ordnungsämter bei
kontrollen zu entlasten
wir wollen auf jeden fall verhindern
dass es zu einem generellen shutdown in
deutschland kommt wir wollen auf jeden
fall verhindern dass kinder nicht mehr
die kitas in die schulen besuchen und
wir wollen möglichst sind alles dafür
tun dass wirtschaftliche entwicklung
ermöglicht werden die steigenden corona
zahlen zwingen kliniken bereits wieder
planbare eingriffe zu verschieben
die kommenden tage werden entscheiden
wie gut deutschland im winter da steht
martin hikel als bezirksbürgermeister
von neukölln wie sinnvoll sind dann aus
ihrer sicht diese beschlüsse
ich finde die alle sehr
nachvollziehbaren sehr sinnvoll also man
kann man muss konstatieren dass
sicherlich jede unterstützung gerade in
den großstädten wichtig ist weil ihm
dort zum geschehen wesentlich
dynamischer ist als in der fläche und
insofern ständiges durchaus richtig und
gut dass da der bund auch entsprechende
angebote macht ob es die unterstützung
durch die bundespolizei ist die übrigens
in berlin auch schon unterwegs ist oder
ob es auch die unterstützung durch sober
koch institut oder die unterstützung der
bundeswehr heißt ich glaube das sind
schon wirklich wichtige maßnahmen und
eine gute unterstützung und letztendlich
zeigt das auch dass eine
gemeinschaftsaufgabe das ist nicht meine
aufgabe die jetzt ein bezirk ein
landkreis alleine bewältigen kann
sondern wenn es irgendwo wirklich brennt
rasmussen hat des wortes dann braucht
man da auch unterstützung um das geld
vorher auch löschen zu können und
insofern das ist gut das ist diese
unterstützung gibt dass da auch die
solidarität am auf allen ebenen großes
haben sie denn genügend feuerwehrleute
um das auch wirklich löschen zu können
oder anders gefragt wie praktikabel ist
das denn tatsächlich also die kollegen
von der bundeswehr wie gesagt die
unterstützen und schon und ich kann auch
sagen wir schaffen das noch und das ist
noch eine beherrschbare aufgabe aber
unter der woche den sparern auf diesen
plätzen wenn es darum geht die masken
pflicht einzuhalten wenn es darum geht
wirklich zu kontrollieren wenn es doch
darum
die menschen mitzunehmen bei diesen
beschlüssen auch dafür muss man
festhalten brauchen wir sicherlich auch
unterstützung aber das machen die
kollegen in den ganzen letzten monaten
und ich kann ihnen beispiele aus
neukölln nennen das nach den ersten
kontrollen zum beispiel in kneipen nach
hygiene konzepten nach dem tragen von
mutter nasenschutz das dann wir wirklich
viele verstöße gehabt hatten ein
beispiel war von 13 kontrollierten
gastronomien und kneipen war nur eine
beanstandungsfrei bei allen anderen gab
es wirklich massive probleme und das hat
sich schon mittlerweile geändert und das
liegt sicherlich auch daran was die
kollegen in den ordnungsbehörden
regelmäßigen abständen die gastronomin
kontrollieren beraten es ist ja nicht
nur ein auf einen auf den deckel geben
sondern auch beratung anbieten und
darauf hinweisen dass es wichtig ist
einen hinweisschilder zu haben noch ein
abstand halten soll
dass man sich in listen eintragen soll
dass die solisten auch nachvollziehbar
sein müssen damit wir damit die
gesundheitsämter auch in der lage sind
im 2 für kontakte nach zu verfolgen
und da wird es schon besser und auch
jetzt ich komme gerade von einer kleinen
kontrolle und auch dort haben wir viele
beratungsgespräche geführt mussten da
auch verwarnungsgelder aussprechen aber
wir haben auch an viele gastronomin
gehabt die vollkommen beanstandungsfrei
waren und im summa summarum muss man
sagen die meisten gastronomen und
gastronomen geben sich wirklich mühe und
bemühen sich hier ein ordentliches ist
auch mal freizeit leben möglich zu
machen und das ist durchaus gut und
insofern die ordnungskräfte kommen
durchaus hinterher aber klar ist auch
wir können nicht vor jedem hauseingang
polizisten oder eine ordnungskraft
stellen sondern wir sind da auch auf die
solidarität auf die mitwirkung der
bürgerinnen und bürger angewiesen weil
so eine pandemie lässt wirklich
ordnungsbehördliche bekämpfen sondern
die lässt sich nur mit den bürgerinnen
und bürgern gemeinschaftlich bekämpfen
und wie rigoros wollen sie dabei
vorgehen sie haben das stichwort
bußgelder genannt sorgt dass wir mehr
einsicht ich glaube es sorgt für einen
sicheren und ich glaube und das haben
wir auch in berlin besprochen das so
wichtig ist dass im zweifel gelder zum
beispiel verwarnungsgelder auch vermehrt
ausgesprochen werden damit zum beispiel
das geld auch sofort einkassiert wird
damit man merkt es ist kein spaß was man
nicht lange warten muss jeder
bußgeldbescheid dann wirklich in die
haustür ein flattert sondern dass man
sofort vor ort das deutlich macht und am
ende die menschen noch merken gerade die
die flat uneinsichtig sind noch davon
gibt es immer mal wieder welche aber ich
möchte auch betonen das sind ausnahmen
und ausnahmen bestätigen die regel
was man schreibt wie youtube lasst doch
die menschen tun was sie wollen wenn man
eine vor erkrankte familie hat dann
sollte man eben nicht tun was man will
aber lasst doch die ungefährdeten in
ruhe und denen nicht alles verbieten
ich kann das gut nachvollziehen dass man
so eine haltung hat aber alleine wenn
ich überlege mir wie viele menschen ich
hätte den letzten wochen und letzten
tagen kontakt gehabt hatte da kann ich
nicht beurteilen werde auf eine
vorerkrankung hat und ich glaube das
können viele menschen auch nicht und das
ist ja wie gesagt doch kein böser wille
und ich glaube durchaus wende ist eine
medizinische behandlung gebe wenn es
eine impfung gebe dann könnte man
sicherlich noch mal ganz anders mit so
einer pandemie umgeben
aber wir haben es ihnen noch nicht und
das bedeutet wir müssen verhindern dass
bei denen ankommt die hat schwächer sind
damit man eben verhindert dass menschen
auf intensivstationen landen
dass dann dort auch menschen sterben sie
einsam sterben und das gilt es ja genau
zu verhindern und dafür müssen wir ein
stück weit zu uns zurück nehmen und das
ja das wird schwer aber ich glaube dass
es für einen guten zweck von am ende
geht es darum dass wir auch bei uns
menschen leben retten und wir haben sie
im frühjahr wirklich gut geschafft weil
sich alle wirklich dran gehalten haben
wir haben keine bilder aus italien
gehabt und pflege an der stelle zu sagen
der ist no glory on prevention das
bedeutet wir waren erfolgreich dafür
bekommen wir aber kein lob sondern wir
sind eigentlich alle ganz glücklich und
haben das machte ihr das gefühl breit
ipanema existiere gar nicht nach den
hickel vielen dank für den moment wir
schauen jetzt noch mal nach frankfurt
denn wir wollen noch einen anderen blick
wagen und zwar natürlich auch und auch
das heißt es hier
es hat ja auch was zu tun noch mit der
gastronomie es geht ja nicht nur darum
wer feiert sondern auch wo gefeiert wird
und auch das ist ein ganzer bereich der
davon betroffen ist nina niebergall
wieder jetzt auch in frankfurt und wie
ich sehe jetzt drin irgendwo sag mal wo
und wo genau und was sagt die
gastronomie zu dem was da heute
entschlossen wurde
denen gehört diese war hier ihr seid
jetzt ja direkt betroffen gerade von
dieser sperrstunde 23 uhr hier in
frankfurt
wie findet ihr das ich muss ehrlich
sagen heute ist der erste tag und ist
nicht viel los die leute haben halt
generell bisschen angst wegen corona
aber auf jeden fall ist das hat für uns
negativ weil besonders am wochenende
haben wir bis 23 uhr hier auf gehabt und
jetzt wenn wir um 23 uhr zu machen das
heißt um 10 uhr sei es muss die gäste
sagen bitte langsam geht nach hause und
für uns ist das definitiv giftig sowieso
was ein schwimmer jahren schwierige jahr
wegen cologne und jetzt wieder halt
wegen sperrstunde mussten wir schauen
kannst du es denn nachvollziehen die
entscheidung das jetzt sperrstunde 23
uhr ist auch mit dieser uhrzeit ehrlich
gesagt nein weil den ganzen tag gibt den
cologne und ab 23 uhr was passiert dann
und für uns gastronomen sowie so haben
wir schwierigkeiten überhaupt zu beleben
und was passiert aber du weißt du was
ich will wenn die leute jetzt nach hause
gehen
das ist gerade schon gesagt das war ein
schwieriges halbes jahr
mit welchem gefühl mit welcher stimmung
schaust du denn jetzt in die zukunft
ich muss ehrlich sagen mein gehirn ist
momentan wieder in seiner wie im märz
das waren zwei monate ich bin jeden tag
aufgestanden
wir haben neun mitarbeiter gehabt keine
haben wir gekündigt die weitere gerne
bezahlt und ich wusste nicht was morgen
passiert und jetzt wieder weiß ich nicht
was morgen passiert und wir haben
fixkosten von tausende von euros und
wenn wir wieder um 23 uhr zu machen
das holen wir niemals wieder rein das
ist die wahrheit hat bei uns gastronom
ja also ihr seht ist es das ist hier mit
zukunftsängsten verbunden das ist eine
entscheidung die trifft die gastronomen
hier in frankfurt schon sehr
auch diese sperrstunde das gilt jetzt
erst mal für zehn tage hier
bis nächsten sonntag wie es danach
weitergeht das wird sich dann zeigen und
das wird auch wieder davon abhängig sein
wie sich die neue infektionen hier
entwickeln - dank für diese eindrücke
läufer frankfurt abschließend noch
einmal nach berlin martin hikel
bezirksbürgermeister von dem bezirk
neukölln
auch sie haben ja im kiez auch der
verändert sich nämlich gerade an
auch nachhaltig haben sie die sorge dass
da was passiert
das ist ein ganz große befürchtung und
zwar unabhängig von der sperrstunde
wollen wenn ich die gastronomen
angefragt habe wenn ich mit den menschen
ins gespräch gekommen bin
dann haben die schon gesagt wenn man
sich daran hält dann hat man nur ein
bruch die möglichkeiten bruchteilen
seiner kundschaft in den innenräumen zu
beherbergen und das ist schon ein
riesiges problem wir als bezirk und das
land berlin hat dann auch entschieden
dass beispielsweise außenflächen auch
einen seiten eingehaust werden dürfen
dass man da problemlos andere anträge
stellen kann es sich lohnen zum beispiel
elektrischen heizstrahler hinzustellen
wohl wissend dass auch diese plätze
natürlich nicht das kompensieren was man
in normalen jahren hat und insofern habe
ich eine große befürchtung wenn das sich
noch eine größere unterstützung gibt
seitens der senatsverwaltung des des
bundes aber natürlich auch eine große
solidarität der stammkunden
man kann ja auch stammt konnte seine
kneipe weiterhin unterstützen
dann ist die gefahr groß dass gerade die
kleinen kneipen die inhabergeführten
kneipen diesen herbst und winter nicht
überleben und das fördert sicherlich die
städte nachhaltig verändern weil sind
oftmals gilt genau jene gastronomen die
so ein bild eines kitas mit geprägt
haben und regen und die letztendlich
auch das ausmachen warum menschen gerne
dahin gehend insofern haben wir großes
interesse mit einem unserer
möglichkeiten die gastronomen
gastronomen zu unterstützen unter diesen
etwas was ist etwas ziemlich schwierigen
voraussetzungen
wir haben hier fallen auch in frankfurt
gehört und gutem anteil schreibt auch
via facebook dass sie für schutz sei
aber bei
diese sperrstunde denn soll habe ich bis
23 uhr oder bis morgens früher unterwegs
bin ist da egal schreibt sie
das virus hat kein zeitlimit das bringt
denn aus ihrer sicht tatsächlich 23 uhr
man muss erst mal irgendeine zeit
festlegen und ich glaube 23 uhr ist eine
durchaus abgewogene entscheidung weil
sich halt ich habe irgendeiner uhrzeit
muss man sagen da laden muss dann dicht
sein und dicht sein wenn man eine
sperrstunde möchte und ich glaube es
auch klug gewählter zeitpunkt weil ab
irgend einer gewissen uhrzeit wird man
dann mit laufendem abend dann auch immer
etwas freimütiger wenn man auch dort
alkohol konsumiert dann kommt man sich
näher dann hält man sich nicht mehr so
sehr an die abstände dann wird man etwas
waghalsiger und ich glaube genau das
gilt es ja auch zu verhindern auch ein
symbol und ein signal zu setzen dass man
ihm genau das und so eine pandemie ja
unterlassen soll und was man genau in so
einem pagnia auf eben solche feiern auch
möglichst verzichten soll
und ja das ist ein totaler einschnitt
und das ist für die gastronomen
gastronom wirklich wirklich eine sehr
sehr schwere zeit und ich glaube da ist
es auch wichtig dass es unterstützung
gibt aber ich glaube dass diese
entscheidung durchaus richtig ist auch
um ein signal zu setzen bei den menschen
bei den bürgerinnen und bürger und auch
ein bewusstsein zu schaffen dass wir
eben kein normales jahr haben und ich
glaube dass ist auch ein stück weit die
botschaft und das geht auch nur auf
diese art und weise
weil die alternative wäre zuzuschauen
die steigenden infektionszahlen zu
beobachten um irgendwann festzustellen
es geht gar nichts mehr und das wäre
dann tatsächlich der ruhigen für viele
gewerbetreibende aber verlagert sich an
das schreiben und fragen hier auch ganz
viele verlagert sich das nicht einfach
23 uhr die kneipe macht zu mein gott
angeht waldheim und macht weiter ich
glaube uneinsichtige wird es immer geben
sowie auch im sommer uneinsichtige in
den berliner parks auch rücksichtslos
feiern gemacht haben und auch die grünen
anlagen zerstört haben und nachhaltige
schäden verursacht haben
aber ich möchte auch sagen dass da nicht
die mehrheit ich glaube dass ein
großteil und das haben wir auch die
beiträge gezeigt sehr wohl auch das
einsehen und sich ihrer verantwortung
bewusst sind und ich glaube die muss man
stützen die muss man unterstützen
und ich glaube die menschen haben auch
kein problem damit dass man eben sich
ein stück weit zurück hält und für alle
anderen
die da vielleicht noch zweifeln oder die
vielleicht sich über einen sommer ein
normales verhalten wieder angewöhnt
haben da muss man auch das signal setzen
dass wir haben kein normales jahr und
ich glaube ja insofern ist das durchaus
richtig dass wir das machen
und nein wir werden nicht vor jedem
hauseingang einen polizisten stellen
oder eine ordnungskraft ist doch
unmöglich wir sind ja kein totalitärer
staat sondern wir werden es wird
sicherlich auch ein stück solidarität
der menschen ankommen und sicherlich
auch darauf ankommen dass man sich
zurücknimmt und sicherlich auch im
zweifel wenn man davon mitbekommt dass
man auch solche partys aufgelöst werden
aber klar ist auch es geht nicht an
jeder ecke und es soll noch gar nicht an
die decke gehen aber es muss an den
richtigen stellen funktioniert in der
öffentlichkeit und ich glaube auch dass
man da an die solidarität der nachbarn
denken mussten dass man da auch sagen
muss man kommt miteinander ins gespräch
und tauscht sie auch vielleicht darüber
aus was macht ihnen hoffnung hoffnung
machen mir viele von den beiträgen von
den menschen die heute interviewt worden
sind die durchaus so sehen auch von den
beiträgen die im chat gekommen sind dass
man durchaus sieht man hat eine
verantwortung man möchte ja nichts denn
nächsten seinen nächsten anstecken
niemand hat ja ein großes interesse
irgendwie des virus bewusst zu
verbreiten sondern es gibt da schon eine
große skepsis sondern eine große
unterstützung dafür
diese maßnahmen einzuspringen also diese
pandemie einzuschränken und ich das gibt
mir hoffnung und ich glaube genau das
ist auch der geist an denen unsere
kanzlerin heute appelliert hat dass man
eben genau jene menschen unterstützt und
sagt dass wie eurostat weiter verbreiten
es geht auch um solidarität der gesamten
gesellschaft letzte frage sie haben
heute besuch von der heute show ein team
war bei ihnen ist die noch irgendwie
nach lachen zumute
naja ich finde man nur weil wir an ihm
haben darf man nicht auch lachen und
seine witze machen darum hat er schon in
ordnung dass man auch etwas humorvoll
mit umgeht und ich glaube aber die
thematik muss man nicht unbedingt
bagatellisieren aber man kann sicherlich
über die ist ja mal kritiker über die
skeptiker über diejenigen die meinen ist
ja alles nicht zustimmen das kann man
durchaus auch ironisch aufs korn nehmen
auf seine art und weise individuellen
und insofern ich komme auch in der
pandemie dürfen gelangen
nach den hügel bezirksbürgermeister von
neukölln danke nach berlin zu dieser
späten stunde dankeschön
die neuen schönen abend ja das war's zdf
heute live sperrstunde gegen korona wir
haben es gehört achtsamkeit zusammenhalt
damit appelliert aber natürlich auch
verständnis aber wir haben auch viele
sorgen gehört und die machen nicht um 23
uhr schluss in diesem sinne kommen sie
gut ins wochenende
bis zum nächsten mal